that perfect score feel pretty good
oh you know I'm just so happy I'm being
come for painting obviously but in the
inside I was like the risk paid off
perfect ends all around including guest
judge Olivia newton-john
she is so beyond her years it amazes me
lovely specially human being that one
with her daughter Chloe watching olivia
judge her own grease dance were you so
proud of mom tonight so you're like
professional when she would go away I
would put the tape on replay at night
when I would go to sleep so I would give
chariot what she want
you rode Louie backstage you wrote him a
week we will not forget this when she
felt I was going underneath you
literally what would await on me you are
not going anywhere
Paula's vintage Vogue wasn't good enough
to earn another week I can't help but
feel relieved when we packed up to come
out here I said okay y'all playing on
two weeks well it's been six but what
everyone's gonna miss Paula brought
baked treats each week oh you didn't
we have to talk